[Musik]
Afghanistan Gaddafi für den Sudan aus
Fantasie feresten Linden Teufelsflehen
mein Herz sogar Gottes Initiative auf
aapke stoppt in mythischen Tierversuchen
ausgefallener Garten erben agnes Software Angst
Matsu Clinton siehe Tapas Waffel Garage
macht es sehr irisch Beta vom Time
Magazine plötzlich, wer nicht betonte
Peso und Ereignis selbst Odin, wie es die
Biome sind, zu denen jede Hemisphäre werden muss. Wer
ich bin, danke, dass du mich hier eingeschlossen hast.
Ich bin fertig in der Notaufnahme. Ich
gebe es als Schätzung für ein neues Computerarsenal weiter,
das er im Internet freigeschaltet hat
wird Dänisch auf diesem Nationalheim Nun,
ich habe immer von Büchern gehört. Ich höre
in den Büchern von Computern, aber im
Alter von sechzehn Jahren habe ich tatsächlich gehört,
dass in Herat ein Internetcafé eröffnet wurde
und das nur mein Cousin und meine
Brüder dort hingehen konnten  war nicht
geeignet für ein Mädchen in den
Club zu gehen und damals war ich hier, dass
dies eine Zauberkiste ist, die dich mit
der Welt verbindet und du kannst mit den
Leuten und dir reden  Sie können alle Informationen finden, die
Sie wollten, und ich
wollte diese Zauberkiste wirklich unbedingt sehen, und ich wurde
darauf bestanden, dass ich zu dieser einzigartigen Angelegenheit gehen wollte,
und natürlich wollten meine Brüder
am Anfang nicht, aber später
konnte ich sie überzeugen und  Ich konnte
zum ersten Mal zu diesem Endtäter gehen,
als ich das Internet und den Computer benutzte,
und ich fand heraus, dass
es eine andere Welt gibt, die existiert, von der ich
nichts wusste. Wir lebten damals
in einer Dunkelheit, die wir nicht kannten  hatte Zugang zu
irgendwelchen Informationen oder Büchern oder irgendetwas oder
irgendwelchen Nachrichten, wir wussten nicht, was
in der Welt vor sich ging, was auch immer wir sahen, es war nur
im Fernsehen, was er als dieses Pokal-
Fanzine in einer Art Fuchsie sehen konnte,
ja, aber es gibt nur  Eine Bibliothek in
Herat, die sehr alte Bücher enthielt, und es
gab keine Fähigkeitsinformationen, und es
gab Fernseher in Afghanistan, die alle nur
die Shows und Nachrichten zeigten, die mein
Vater und meine Brüder sehen wollten, und wir
hatten keinen wirklichen Zugang zu
Enden  außerhalb davon und ich  Ich glaube, das
war eines Nachts
, als ich sah, dass ich ein so magisches Zauberkästchen für mich war, dass
ich die
Technologie wirklich zum Zentrum meiner
Gebietsnotizen in Yosh Beta machen wollte
Hinweis auf die Harmonie jeder
Aufgabe ein paar behinderte Abende mit ihnen
Computer para añadir krishna Geisel-
Epos ignorieren Ich glaube, mein Herr, ich meine, ich hatte eine
Reise, die mein Leben verändert hat, als ich
dort war, als ich den Computer sah, hat
er mein persönliches Leben verändert und auch
Während meines Berufslebens habe ich mich entschieden, an
die Fakultät für Informatik zu gehen und
dort meinen Abschluss zu machen, und ich habe gesehen, wie
es mich als Person stark macht und
mir Selbstvertrauen gibt, und deshalb wollte ich
der Gemeinschaft etwas zurückgeben
und andere Mädchen ausbilden, also ich  Ich fand
auch einen Intrapreneur und Time Magazine
Hunter me2 me1 des afghanischen schuldigen
Manohar Zionisten
nt of
Streets Association HD Ja, meine Familie
unterstützt mich sehr und die
Familie spielt eine sehr wichtige
Rolle für den Erfolg einer Frau in dem
Land, in so konservativen Ländern
wie Afghanistan und Tex. Gott
sei Dank hatte ich einen Vater, der mich unterstützte
Glauben Sie mir, wie meine Schulen und
meine Universität und auch meine Karriere aussehen, also bin ich
dem Gott wirklich dankbar, eine solche Familie zu haben,
wie es in der Saison
zwischen dem Irish Fest ist, und ich nannte Sie Ihre
Brut Ozzy, die Sexvisum Cynthiana
Putin macht  Das Projekt CMEs wütende
Feministin befiehlt Madonna Yash Weston
und Slaw Hamdi digitale Scans Patiala
South Catotti in Patiala Mishka spürt
Mittelamerika auf Valen Informationen in der
Umgebung von Afghanistan und landet in
Lawson, die an diesem Marathon teilnehmen, sicher, dass es
ein Projekt ist, das wir vor fast zwei
Jahren gestartet haben, aber  Ich meine, letztes Jahr haben
wir hauptsächlich an der Kaffeeformel gearbeitet
, und die Idee war,
den Frauen bei den
Bauern in Afghanistan besonders zu helfen
der Safran und wir beschlossen, stolz darauf
zu sein, den Safran in die USA zu bringen, aber wir
essen, dass wir in diesem Monat nicht
so viele Kunden finden konnten, also beschlossen wir,
es mit einigen Teenagern zu mischen, und es war das erste mit
einem T, aber nicht  Es war bei uns nicht so beliebt
, aber dann haben wir uns entschieden, es
mit einem Kaffee zu kombinieren, und Sie stimmen für eine
Weile über den Kaffee ab, und jetzt haben
wir ein gutes formelles und gutes Produkt
namens Bright Citizen entwickelt, und die Idee ist, zu
helfen und zu unterstützen  die Frau und der
Prozentsatz von 50% der Gewinne
geht auf die Stiftung zurück, dass wir
Frauen helfen und sie trenden können und auch
den Safran von den weiblichen Bauern binden
und hoffen, dass Safran
in Zukunft durch Opium ersetzt werden kann  als Mann
g-verdammt que kein Einkommen
Suvarna Steven Van Alen Café treffen
Opiumtrinker eine Person ist böse im Opium,
das mit Safranfarm und Vermögen gefunden wird, wenn
es 54.000 ha ist, faul oder plötzliche Qual zu sein,
oft gekennzeichnet durch Reichtum Ahmedabad in Produkten
und einem Motorpreis  das ist extrem
lo  oks uns Produktkosten pro Produkt
genau und Afghanistan ist
bekanntlich eines der opiumproduzierenden Länder
der Welt und leider bei
den internationalen Gebern und der
Regierung lange Zeit damit beschäftigt
die Farmer davon zu überzeugen ihre
Farmen mit etwas zu platzieren  teuer sein und
auch die gleichen Preise haben, dass
sie es so schnell in bar machen, und Zefram war
einer davon, und zum Glück haben wir eine
gute Safranqualität, besonders
im Westen in Herat, und die meisten
Bauern ersetzen ihn gerade jetzt und sie
sie  kann schneller Geld verdienen und es ist
auch so teuer wie Opium, aber
was wir suchen, ist, dass
die Regierung daran arbeitet
, den Safran in ganz Afghanistan herzustellen, den
die meisten formellen und mehr
Bauern versuchen  Überzeugen Sie sie
, das OPM durch ein Zephyr zu ersetzen
, das kein Kaffee trinkt, Colonel.
Ich werde Ihnen einen einfachen Anzug schicken,
er ist fertig, die Mitte selbst
lackieren, was eine Mission sein muss  Die Verlobung
aus dem Café in South Khan kam in
Harmonie, also lucania cacistis Yamazaki
Siri familias de lys Tellergeschäft sprudelnd
sehen Sie, wie viele in Gedanken organisiert sind
Afghanistan Ghalib de familias ein Flan
ASEAN China Skin Van Wir sind auf diesem
sowjetischen ish, Kriegers zu garnieren
Slavia Pakistan im Nirananda Hamza
optimierte usw. gereinigte Haut für den Weg
, die Vereinbarung zu brechen Sun Khans Mäntel
, um jeden Tag im Cache
einzuhaken Afghanistans entzückender Ärger
, der als Landis registriert ist, beginnt nein, es ist eine
Einheit, die sich leicht Medina-Militär nähert
Pinner Hollywood-Veteranenkrankenhäuser Elva
im Jahr  Strahlungskuckucks-
Toast nein intern um 9:00 Uhr auf CBS-
Maschinenräumen des Jahres T-Shirt offenes Eisen auf die
Kommunisten in Afghanistan und Amazo,
versteckt im Islam, ist Creighton erschreckend
und fühlt, dass alle Kommunisten
Tim zusehen sollen, wie Eden Neiman Dean Bhuvah Flynn
kommt und kommt  Wir hatten Spaß mit uns draußen auf dem
Heimatland der Kämpfer und verstanden die
Sowjets in neunzehn an diesem
Nachmittag.  Berger klicken Sie auf Lebenslauf erhalten Nonsan
Einheit Abschnitt keine Insignien Mandi Taliban
Kabul Insel auf Tava Schriftarten kämpfen wenig
und Ecija Putin ganz eigene Krankheit LOM
5000 ist ein Gedanke von 9/11 Bombadil in
den USA sind Afghanistan die Neigung in der DMZ
hilft, Osama bin Laden im ersten Oktett zu finden
Sue's Amman Madeira nicht aus Veranstaltung bei
Machir und die gerade
gebogene Ashlee's Leine der amerikanischen Nation in Kabul im
Veda Donato Norton OS werden in
Afghanistan bestellt Zika AIDS Kaftan Kolonist
haftet einfach, um bald Emlyn geeignet
ist Elam Mia SS Lionheart Millionen
Erstling ein zeitgesteuertes ist ein  CLIA-Urteil
Lösegeld in den Ländern Elbas Gliedmaße Normas erste eine
heiße Million Erwähnungsaugen Fatima
das Fleisch stand für Einkommensfonds Deutscher
Vytas besteht in Vega und Caracas hi
Katya über
Elfentürmen und Zivilfahrzeugen
Untergang in DotA Taliban Er versteckt
Schecks höher in Kabul, das er hoffte
Der Fehler, furchtlos zu sein, lehrte em viel Doc ein
Insekt Clifton, das auf Tellin Lord
Vita einsackt, gräbt in der Ferne filigran, um Zoe Bertram zu debride, das
wir nicht hatten  Wir würden Thurmond
die Taliban seit 8000 ärgern, so Kuckuck,
Kiki Afghanistan von Teenager Damas. Ich werde
zufriedenstellen. Ich bin London, funktioniert es,
aber gut gesündigt
Es gab damals die Leute und aber
es gab damals auch Hoffnung, dass wir
zur Schule gehen können wir können zur
Universität gehen und viele der Frauen waren damals in
meinem Alter, die Mädchen waren
so begeistert, dass viele von ihnen waren  waren
lange zu Hause und die
Schule öffnete sich für sie, also war es eine Quelle
der Hoffnung und Quelle der ED und auf eine
Weise, dass sie sich eine bessere
Zukunft für sich vorstellen können, also ich meine, wir
hatten nicht so viel Infrastruktur
Zur Zeit des Jahres 2003 weigerten sich immer noch die
meisten Familien,
Ihre Mädchen auf die Schulen zu schicken, aber mit der
Zeit haben sich viele Dinge geändert,
und wir haben eine Menge Fortschritte gemacht, wenn wir das
heutige
Siedlungsgefühl von 2003 danach vergleichen  al-maliki
West P  Resident George Bush dann Zeke
immer das Taliban éclair Costa Mesa
seein Grundwasserleiter Gerüche gebraten durchsiebt Aslam
mutlos Alabama gehashte Version aus
Pakistan hier trank tes in den Slums
Eschaton schlampige filieo Politiker
total böse eine Frau
Varys lineare Gleichungen oder Duvall und
sie sind Dyneema Vida dafür, dass sie das zeigen
Die Beschlagnahme war träge, träge,
Cindy Hoffman, Afghanistan, nahm in
der nächsten Nia Mohammed persönlich
über Khalifa teil, und doch erwähnen wir auf der Toilette
tatsächlich den Scanner von Mutant.
Natürlich hoffen wir, weil
Afghanistan eine junge
Bevölkerung als Haus der ist  Bevölkerung
sind sie unter 18 Jahre alt, also denke ich,
dass wir Hoffnung für die Zukunft haben, und ich
verstehe, dass wir heute einige
Schwierigkeiten mit der aktuellen
politischen Situation und mit dem Kondom mit unseren
Nachbarn haben, die sich bei unserer Wahl der
Politik in unsere Stabilität einmischen  und mit
der Zeit müssen sie verstehen, dass, wenn
Afghanistan instabil ist, es auch
betroffen ist, liebe Grafen  ries und liebe Leute
und es ist besser, dass sie
unseren Regierungen geholfen und mit ihnen zusammengearbeitet haben - für
mich ein stabiles Land zu haben, und
leider muss ich sagen,
dass viele, auch gute Dinge
passieren, eine Menge Fortschritte, auch
was die Medien betrifft
diesen Teil nicht zeigen ja Afghanistan ist immer noch wir
haben Krieg noch gibt es einige unsichere
'ti in der Hauptstadt des Landes
aber es passieren auch viele Dinge im
Vergleich zu 2003 2002 sehen wir
aus wir haben 37% der Bevölkerung
der Schule  Frauen Wir haben mehr als
30 % weibliche Studenten an der Universität Wir
haben viele Frauen als politische
Entscheidungsträgerinnen und Ministerinnen und als Führungspersönlichkeiten
Wir haben viele Frauen, die ihre
eigenen Startups gesehen haben, also haben
wir heute ein Krankenhaus, wir haben viele  von Wurzeln, die es geschaffen hat
und viele Schulen gebaut haben, welche Medien oder
ich oder ich weiß nicht, das westliche Denken
zeigt nicht, dass es ein Leben gibt.
Ja, ich stimme zu, dass es ein
Sicherheitsproblem gibt, das eine
Herausforderung darstellt  existiert und leider ist die
Taliban-Kultur noch in einigen
südlichen Provinzen in Afghanistan
vorhanden, aber ich denke mit der Zeit
wird sich alles ändern, weil
wir eine neue Generation sind und neue Generationen
nicht wollen
Afghanistan hat eine ziemlich
noch unsichere Nische zerstört, die neuere
der Sterne ist, auf einer Ebene,
um so viel zu beherbergen, Pferd undichtes Ventil mr.
Feist und Esther stylisch indisch, wenn
diese Busse komplett sind, aber Bändchen
der Organisation Gitarren sind
leider
das Gesetz der Freiwilligkeit zweier
Frauen wird vom Parlament
wegen ein paar Dingen nicht verabschiedet, die sie
nicht mögen und das Problem ist da
Damit mögen es nicht nur Männer, wenn Männer das nicht
tun, sondern auch die Frauen haben
diese Distanz unterstützt, und ja, es gibt
eine einzige Instanz, in der die Frau existiert, und
wir können das nicht ignorieren, und ich kann nicht sagen,
dass es nicht wahr ist, aber es ist wahr
Das Gute daran, dass dies heute passiert,
ist, dass es Medien und soziale
Medien gibt, die über die Geschichten berichten und
die Regierung zwingen, das
Gesetz zu zwingen, Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, und dank
der Medien werden viele Fälle gelöst
und es gibt sie auch  Internationale
Gemeinschaft, die arbeitet und die
Regierung erzwingt, und heute sehen wir,
wenn Sie den Rückgriff der Römer auf
die Gewalt sehen, denn heute ist jeder
Bericht ihre Erwähnung, in der Vergangenheit gab
es viel  von Gewalt, aber es wurde nicht
darüber gesprochen, aber heute wird darüber gesprochen,
und ich denke, das Reden hilft der
Regierung und den Menschen, ein
bisschen von unserer Politik zu sein, dies ernst zu nehmen,
und wenn sie das verwenden, wissen Sie
, ein imposantes  Hängematte auf stilvollem
Mohanty Social und hergestellt in Kernan
extrem einige gute Vans sind Rat
annum Freiheit sowjetisches und US-Internet
und ein Fermion von Feline im Ofen und
Baumwollengel überschreibt ihren Rapper
in Sunita, den er für höhere
Anhänglichkeit oder Übelkeit von Eliza vorgebracht hatte
Top-Fotografie Marshall Sahlins von
Ausdrucksfilm-Porträt Es war Anita
über Uni gegen Katsu
[Musik]
Video Gnade des Kletterns Schlock
Köder für mich besonders genossen auf diesem
Video von YouTubes estelí sein erster
Schaden für die Interaktion in Afghanistan auf
speziell vertraute Domina  Attentäter hier
hilft jeder Moses zu oft zwanzig shmita
mir Charlie es ist nicht für mich es das Ziel
Sie E-Mail Inc der Seele zum
Glück habe ich so viele  leisten sich Klischee-
Visier-Schönheiten Fela-Fans
, wenn ein Motor eine solche
Krankheit auslöst, die er befreundet hat, und gut klingt, es ist
schnell, gut, wild, lustige Wendung, Arriba,
aber ich weiß für mich, dass sie uns dieses
Rösterbündel gekauft hat  ihr
ähm nicht zustimmen sie stand ataktisch eine öffnung
vermeidet den sack Tom der suti Alan
trifft sich mit einem freund auf feldern und ärgert
afghanistan gebaut für ich bin kein
saddam über tok tok auch versteckt aus pvc und
aluminium vor der energiefeuchten indigenen
trafen site camus und shalumu diwali  Mafia-
Telefon und er erging es in Middleton. Ich denke,
dass sich in den sozialen Medien viele Dinge geändert haben,
nicht nur für die Frauen, sondern
auch für die Politiker, und wenn
wir unsere Regierungen dazu bringen, transparenter zu essen,
und es gibt viele
Fälle, in denen das passiert  Korruption sind mit
der Gewalt gegen zwei Frauen, die ich
heute sehen konnte, wenn es um
soziale Medien geht, reagieren viele der Leute
positiv und
sie unterstützen die Frau  n und
sie sind nicht einverstanden mit den Leuten,
die die Frau zwingen, und ich muss
sagen, dass es vor ein paar Jahren nicht
der Fall war, aber heute kann ich sehen, dass ich in den
vielen Kommentaren besonders Männer
zu unterstützen begann  und sie
würden sagen, dass es aufhören sollte und
es ist gut, dass alles eine positive
Sache ist, die passiert, und ein Beispiel, wie
Sunita es zeigt, und mit diesem
Rappen und den Liedern, die viele Leute
gehört haben, und sie verstehen es und es
sollte sein  Ich denke, das ist die Bildung
zu der Zeit, die wir von diesen Herausforderungen meistern können,
und leider können wir nicht. Wir
haben nicht diese Magie, damit dies
sehr schnell in großen Städten passiert. Wir sehen,
dass viele Veränderungen passieren, aber in
kleineren  Stadt immer noch und verspricht ein
Herrschergebiet, immer noch gibt es einen Verlust von denen,
die auf diesem
existieren  Igger beendete
Musik nicht glücklich, so dass Sie
ein zweistufiges Informatik-Erben
Allegheny haben, das auf dem robusten afghanischen Softwareunternehmen Zitadelle versteckt ist
, das Medienanfragen
zu DeKalb, einer Hommage an Dean-Kollegen in
irgendeiner Software-FEMA, auf dem Tisch unter schnell
und für Shi Danai Unternehmen Bharat und geerdet hat
Ricky Human Bharat ein NGO-Geist und die
Bewegung ist ein Altar für Shell und
Armas, keine würzige Miso-Wolke wie jedes
andere Essen - Frau.  McDonald-Mutter kommandiert ein
Antitoxin, danisha Poudre ist Tunesien,
Jemen. Als wir die
afghanische Software starteten, waren wir eine der ersten
weiblichen Tech-SEOs, und es war nicht leicht,
von einer sehr männlich dominierten Branche begrüßt zu werden,
dass weibliche Unternehmen kommen
und sie  sagen, dass sie zwei
Verträge machen können und natürlich, dass es
viele Herausforderungen gab, mystisch
waren, aber diese Zeit war viel und
für uns, eine Frau einzustellen und zur Arbeit zu gehen
und mit einem Auftragnehmer wie Ihnen
als Auftragnehmer zu arbeiten  Regierungen
und Abgaben all diese Herausforderungen
, wie wir diese Herausforderungen
wieder meistern, es hat mir bei der
Digitalisierung geholfen und als Chicken
Intrapreneur Digital in einem Tech-
Unternehmer zu werden, gab es eine Zeit, in der
es nicht sicher war, weiter zu arbeiten
als  Für einen Auftragnehmer war es nicht sicher, nach draußen zu gehen,
und es war für meine Mitarbeiter nicht sicher
, zur Arbeit zu gehen und zu sagen, dass
sie in diesen
Verträgen oder in dieser Firma und zu dieser
Zeit als Gleichgestellte arbeiteten  Ich finde einfach heraus, wie ich
meine Kunden finden kann und mich nicht
auf die Grenze eines Landes verlassen kann, dass einige
Menschen eine Entscheidung für mein Leben
und für mein Unternehmen treffen können, und deshalb habe
ich die Schönheit der sozialen Medien von
LinkedIn und mir geschnitten  Ich war immer dort registriert
und stolz darauf, dort meine Kunden zu finden,
und später Francesca
Rouille, die meine ersten Investoren waren, die mich finanziert haben
für seine Firma und wir bekamen
einen Vertrag und später fing er an
, in unsere Idee zu investieren, eine
Online-Plattform aufzubauen, um
Frauen zu helfen, eine Stimme zu haben, und sie können
Blogs schreiben und über Ihre
Geschichten sprechen, und sie können es auch  Für
die Inhalte bezahlt werden, die sie bereitstellen, und
so hat sich alles für mich
und meine Gedanken geändert. Tomoko Hollett ist in der Tat eine
Sache, die das New Yorker Magazin sprudelnd organisiert
begannen
, unsere Einnahmen für den Aufbau des Ideenzentrums zu verwenden, begannen
sie, die Mädchen darin zu schulen,
wie man mit dem
Computer arbeitet und wie Technologie Ihr Leben verändern kann,
und vor allem
ihr Selbstvertrauen gewinnen und eine digitale
Stimme haben, um über die Dinge zu sprechen, die sie haben
Sie können nicht reden, sie könnten eine
Umgebung schaffen, in der sie
Ihren Ausweis nicht teilen müssen, aber sie können einen
Entenmann-Ausweis verwenden und über die Dinge reden
, zu denen sie gezwungen sind, ihn zu behalten und zu
verstecken, und das war eine Menge
Herausforderungen für mich und Tom Scott auf dem
Gelände in Tracy genau eine Etikette sind
Ischämie Hulton Mann g-verdammt Künstlernachlässe
Ich kenne Mr.  Fawley Man
- Mia Public Amado de Cadiz octoroon uns
auf einer Aufzählung Connie Minuten es ist
beides, dass wir einen Anwalt von
vielen Zuschauern und Benutzern haben und dann
redet jemand über Sachen, die
sie zuerst sind - für viele lange Zeit, um
nicht zu reden  darüber und für Frauen, wenn
Sie nicht sprechen können, auch wenn Sie manchmal
wissen, dass Sie in solch sehr konservativen
Ländern sogar
mit Ihren engen Freunden
und Familien über Ihre persönlichen Gefühle sprechen können, weil Sie Angst haben, dass
jemand dies wahrscheinlich zu Ihrer
Familie und Ihnen bringt  Es wird Zufall haben,
wegen dem, was du fühlst und was du
reden wolltest,
aber dann ist dieses Verzeihen dieser Plattform für
das Mädchen, darüber zu reden, dass sie
über alles schreiben könnten, was sie wollten,
und alles ist ein Traum, und es
war offen, meine ich  Sie konnten sehen, dass die
Leute auf ihre Jahresgeschichten oder
ihr Gespräch reagierten, und sie haben keine Angst, dass
sie nicht reden dürfen, wenn sie reden und jemand so ist, wie
jemand ist, der sie
betritt, aber das ist wa  sa Plattform, dass
sie offen darüber reden kann, was
sie wollen, und später konnte man
sehen, dass sie Selbstvertrauen bekommen, sobald
sie angefangen haben zu reden, sie können dieses
Selbstvertrauen bekommen und sie können anfangen,
offen zu reden, und sie brauchen es nicht  zu
vermeiden, dass der Übergang Cassandra sehen
besuchen für zunehmende mrs.  Reagan Dozier
verschwand nkv Ausdruck in Diamant und
anfangs so Allen de obras war Internet
und Künstler in DMV oben sind klar und
die Lautsprecher sind verringert oder Empfindungen
Olin Wert nervös besuchte Arsenal ist
es auf Anwalt Gräueltaten vertraut zu sehen,
dass die Privatsphäre über unserem
Haus liegt  schuld zug initialisieren legende
DiMaggio ihn tor sie sind nicht
als internet bestimmt ihr arm der fry künstler ich
meine ich meine wenn ich darüber spreche ist es
nicht nur familie manchmal will die community
dich auch nicht hören und sie
will nicht  Auf einige dieser
Dinge reagieren sie sehr schlecht
, deshalb die Digitalisierung und die
Hilfe, den Frauen zumindest eine
zusätzliche Stimme zu geben, um über das zu sprechen, was
sie wollen, und zu dieser Zeit bauen wir
diese Plattform für Frauen auf, damit sie
sich frei fühlen können und
Sie  Was auch immer sie darüber reden wollten
, aber ich komme auf Ihren Punkt zurück
, ja, die Hälfte der Bevölkerung hat
immer noch keinen Zugang, und wenn sie
einen haben, beweisen wir  Ihnen
Zugang zu den Informationen zu verschaffen und sie können
reden, aber es gibt auch ein Problem für
Western, dass, wenn sie Zugang haben, aber
es ein Problem mit ihrer Privatsphäre mit
ihrer Demokratie gibt, und das ist das
Problem, das wir brauchen
Ich sorge dafür, dass ich auf
diese Fragen zurückkomme, dass ich heute Teil
der aufstrebenden Führungskräfte bin, die das Neue genannt werden, jetzt
, wo wir mit Tom
Bernoulli und seinen Web-Stiftungen zusammenarbeiten,
um Verträge für ein wettbewerbsfähiges Web zu fordern,
ein sicherer Ort für alle, die sie können
Fühlen Sie sich dort sicher und natürlich ist die
Tür eine Herausforderung, eine
Digitalisierung zu werden, aber für den Westen, aber wenn
ich in die Länder der konservativen Länder zurückkomme, habe
ich keinen
Zugang zu einem solchen Zugang. Ich denke, die
Digitalisierung gibt der Frau die
Möglichkeit, all das hinter sich zu lassen  von der grenze, die
immer bekannt ist, ist dies, um auf
phaaze zu wachsen, besuchen sie tim berners-lee, so dass zur
souveränität ein finger-internet oder die
villen des vaterlosen internets das
auct sind  Ionen kosten Luftballons auf dem Gelände der Commish
her, auf vis-a-vis fungierte als
Internet ist ihre eigene Teilung und Indien
tut das faule Höschenset wurde
bewusst verschoben Gong Fäustlinge sind ein
tödliches Tier Hobson beharrt und
ashiya's und ärgern sich wieder am baldigen Ende
vom Thron entwaffnet
Ja, beginnen Sie als Eigentumswohnungen mit Internet im
Abseits und trotzen Sie dem Kopf. Ja, und
es ist auch eine Freiheit, aber auch, wo die
Freiheit 3 auch Verantwortung ist, dass wir e
überprüfen müssen, und ich denke, dass das L
nd wie wir es auf Tools basie
t  Die Regierungen übernehmen auch die
Verantwortung dafür,
allen Zugang zum Aufbau der
Infrastruktur zu geben, damit die Menschen sie nutzen
können, und ich denke, dass die
Unternehmen dafür verantwortlich sind, erschwingliche Kosten zu schaffen,
damit die Menschen
einfachen Zugang zum Internet haben und
auch  für die Kampagnen und andere
Fähigkeiten, die sie haben, sich
um die von Ihnen erwähnten privaten Daten und persönlichen Daten
zu kümmern, die Sie haben,
achten Sie darauf, was th  Das Internet, ich meine
, das bedeutet auch, die Regierungen
und Unternehmen zu unterstützen, dass sie
sich um die Daten kümmern müssen, und auch die
Verantwortung der Benutzer,
den Inhalt zu erstellen, dass es ein guter Inhalt ist
, den jeder verwenden kann und ihnen
nicht danach ist  Eine Frau fühlt sich nicht
unwohl oder die Kinder fühlen sich nicht
unwohl, im Internet zu sein, aber
ich verstehe, dass dies alles
Herausforderungen sind, an denen sie arbeiten, und wir
sind als Partner mit der Zeit Bernoulli
und seinen Stiftungen, um diese
Aufmerksamkeit auf diese Probleme zu lenken  Das Versprechen
ist wichtig und wir müssen
ein besseres Web für unsere neue Generation schaffen,
dass sie das Internet als
sicheren und sicheren Ort nutzen, einen offenen Ort, an dem
jeder das Recht hat, es zu nutzen,
aber andererseits denke ich das  Dies ist ein
großartiges Werkzeug, um Frauen und in
konservativen Ländern, in denen sie
keinen Zugang zu den Informationen haben,
keinen Zugang zu irgendwelchen Dingen zu haben, also haben sie
Internet und Technologie und
digitalisieren  ion geben ihnen Hoffnung für
ihre Zukunft,
wenn die Kleinsten ihnen einen Zugang zu
Bildung zu besserer Bildung und
vor allem finanzielle
Unabhängigkeit verschaffen,
und das ist ein Schlüssel, der
die konservativen Länder verändern kann und
dazu bestimmt ist, ihre Sicht auf die Frauen zu ändern
Fähigkeiten sehen, wie viele von
Francesca treffen, die jedes Ereignis identifizieren werden, sind
anständige digitale Bürgergelder Kokon Schmutz
und Taschen Kanada ähm, also sie oder Bild
angemessen Urin als Konzepttechnologien
senden Bestätigung onyomi Telefon, als
Computer Stanwyck ein Pelikan im Poker war
mich zufälliger Blog und  über auch magisch in der
Finanzierung von Geistkatzen und so Phänologie
sagte ein Eskimo Türkische Lira Katas
Telefon von Neshama Löwin Gesang Härte
ist dort ein Farid Annehmlichkeit Fett statt
gefunden ist es, einen mittleren Computer zu beherbergen,
so 2014 und bis Drachen bis
Anand in Verona Oktober  Schmidt Bitcoin
Unfuckin Osment Virtual Environment
Ja, wir haben das digitale Mobiltelefon
mit einem Ziel gestartet, um diese Technologien zu sehen
und  zugängliche Option für alle,
besonders für die Frau in konservativen
Ländern Ich glaube, dass jeder ein
Recht hat und es verdient, dass ich Zugang
zu Bildung und Möglichkeiten nenne, und
wir haben Spaß daran,
den Frauen in Afghanistan ein solches Umfeld zu bieten,
dass sie Programmieren lernen können  Soziale
Medien lernen sie über die Unternehmen
können die finanzielle Bildung und sie
begannen auch mit Bitcoin, es unterstützt
wieder zweitausendzweitausenddreizehn,
als wir eine Plattform hatten, wie ich erwähnte, dass
Frauen annektiert wurden, damit eine Frau Bewerbungen schreiben
konnte, aber wir mussten sie bezahlen
und eine der Herausforderungen ist, dass viele von
ihnen kein Bankkonto hatten oder unser oder
es war, als mit Ihnen die
Benutzer bezahlten, nahmen die Familien ihr Geld und
sie hatten nicht das Geld, war nicht sie, ich meine
die Frau immer  Sie sind die Person, die, wenn
sie das Geld erhalten hat, sie
der Familie und der Unterstützung
Ihrer Familie geben wollte, aber trotzdem, wenn sie wollte,
ein bisschen für sich selbst sagen wollte  Das
konnten sie nicht, weil einige der Familien
ihnen das Geld wegnahmen und wir
wollten sicherstellen, dass die Frau
die Kontrolle über Ihr Geld hat, also sind
wir hier, um die Bitcoins zu kaufen, und wir
begannen, die Bitcoins nach Afghanistan zu bringen
und zahlen durchschnittliche Benutzer und
insbesondere Frauen in einem Bitcoin, weil
es sicher war, es war schnell und sie sind
Kontrolleure und sie sind die Eigentümer des
Geldes und sie könnten tun, was sie
wollen, wenn sie es ihren
Familien geben oder sparen wollten  für
ihre zukunft und es lag an ihm
so wie ein sergeant mit den bitcoins
auf blockchain win-win 2013 engagieren wir
uns koop ich fühle mich anarchie
sieht ganzfeld projekt ein homerun von
saffron cafeterias KD digital schießt eine
map Bitcoin unser vitae  Sehen Sie sie jetzt im
Robota-
Team. Ich stelle mir vor, Team spielt es eine Rolle,
Partikel und unter Gazette, dass die
Versklavung von Yahoo und der
Zeitraum verstanden wird
Mais aus Visa-
Problemen, so dass Rosati Suka Ivanka Trump-
Aktie aufkam, ist ein Visa-Feed,
stellen Sie sich die antiemetische Wirtschaft
vor  oder wir wussten oft, dass ein
Hurenwunschführer wirklich existiert, Ted via
Christopher End on Ich denke, dass
ich diese Art von Geschichten und unsere
Errungenschaften und unsere Herausforderungen als
positive Dinge betrachten würde, denn wenn
wir in einem vom Krieg heimgesuchten Gebiet arbeiten  Wir
arbeiten in einem Land, in dem die Hälfte der
Bevölkerung oder 40 Prozent immer noch
unter Machtarmut leben, und Frauen sehen immer
noch nicht den Sinn der zweiten
Stadt, deshalb denke ich, dass diese
Art von Geschichte Ernährungsberater in
die Gemeinschaft bringen wird  dass sie der Frau vertrauen müssen,
und sie müssen Ihren Fähigkeiten vertrauen,
und ihre Familie muss sie auch
unterstützen, wenn sie sich vor
zwei Jahren ein afrikanisches Mädchen-Roboterteam ansieht  Sie kommen und
weil sie am ERSTEN Robotikwettbewerb teilnehmen wollten,
bekamen sie
die Herausforderung, Arizona zu vereisen,
und dann finden wir heraus, dass wir eines
von zwei Ländern auf der Welt sind, in denen
wir kein Visum bekommen konnten  Auch dieses
Mal nutzen wir die sozialen Medien, weil
wir beschlossen haben, nicht zu schweigen und die
Tradition der Menschen
und der sozialen Medien zu speichern, indem wir den
Zusatz zu den Medien und dann den Zusatz
zu den Menschen in der Welt und
danach dreiundfünfzig Kongressabgeordnete bringen  der eine
Petition unterschrieb und schließlich ins Gefängnis kam,
und er gab Devine-Zertifikate,
aber es ging nicht um die Geschichte, dass die
Mädchen in die Vereinigten Staaten kommen konnten, sondern
darum, was danach passierte, wenn
sie in das Land zurückkehrten, in das sie in die
Länder zurückkehrten  Wie eine
Victoria-Vision einer Hoffnung für ein Land geworden
, das jahrhundertelang die
Fähigkeiten von Frauen in der Wissenschaft und vielen anderen
Industrien ignorierte, brachte uns dieses Team an den
Punkt, an dem wir es schaffen müssen
Der technologische Wandel brachte uns
einen Termin, dass wir verstehen mussten,
dass der Unterricht in Mathematik und Robotik
für Kinder in diesem Alter sehr
wichtig ist und dass
viele der Afghanen heute ihre Ansicht über die Fähigkeiten der Frauen geändert
haben und wir haben  die unterstützung der regierung wir
haben die unterstützung des palawan wir haben
die unterstützung des privaten sektors für
diese initiative, dass wir viel
größere dinge machen können, das ist
alles, was ich denke, diese art von
geschichte ist ein beispiel dafür, wie kann
alles ändern Ich habe mit so
vielen Projekten und so vielen Programmen gearbeitet, und es
hat die Community beeinflusst,
und ich denke, dass sie es sind. Ich denke,
das ist meine größte Errungenschaft,
aber ich denke, das Roboterteam wurde stark
verändert  Dinge, die
für Tausende von
Millionen von Kindern nicht nur in
Afghanistan, sondern auf der ganzen Welt
zu einem Symbol des Mutes wurden, die jeden mit Ermutigung und
Möglichkeiten unterstützen  wo kann man
es passieren
mm-hmm auf die sündhafte handlung ist einem verboten
das der bloße freund und assistent in meinem
effendi bosch war eine cd kassette sagen dann
die south carnegie sagte ctr und ein schild
griff nach dem man beabsichtigen kann oder
die schädel faden zu halten  Individuell in jeder
Position richtig, wenn eine Million Dutzend gestohlen,
leider ja, aber es
hat sich auch viel mit diesem Team geändert,
weil einige der Familien das lösen
und sie einmal sagten, Ihre Mädchen sind auch
Ingenieure Dick, wir werden das als
positive Veränderung sehen und wir  Ich kann sagen,
dass danach die Locken zurück 5540 Wälder
die hier registrierten Studentinnen
Namen in den Robotik-Klassen des Robotik-Wettbewerbs eingetragen haben,
und es ist so, dass
man sehen kann, dass viele
Veränderungen stattfinden und das Roboterteam heute
zu einem Symbol der Hoffnung geworden ist  und Einheit für
ganz Afghanistan. Wir sehen nicht nur
viele Kommentare, und mindestens 90
Prozent der Kommentare sind
positiv, und das ist in der Vergangenheit nicht vorgekommen,
wenn man sich das ansieht  Bedeutung von oder
die Frau sogar eine Intrapreneurin für
politische Entscheidungsträger zu den Medien,
die in den Medien arbeiten, Sie sehen viele
negative Kommentare von Männern, aber für dieses
Team wurde es geändert, und es ist sicher,
dass ich manchmal denke, dass es
wie ein Glanz ist  und Dunkelheit und es
passiert und dieses Team hat uns an
diesen Punkt gebracht und heute
werden wir wegen ihnen die erste
Schule der Wissenschafts-Technologie-
Technik-Kunst-Mathematik-Systemschule mit
dem Schwerpunkt auf KI und Robotik errichten und
glücklicherweise akzeptiert der afghanische
Regierungspräsident das  und wir werden
bald fünf von ihnen in fünf in
Afghanistan bauen, und wegen ihnen ist es ein
Plan, für die nächsten drei
Jahre eine Universität zu bauen, die
das Modell des MIT nimmt und sich auf High-
Tech konzentriert, und wir sind hoffentlich die nächsten Senioren  C
Afghanistan das Land der
High-Tech eher ein Land der Tour
Anwar und alles, was sie dachten, es ist
afghanisch sechs afghanische Mädchen familias
nichkhun's I'm versus Ashley  Im Rahmen des INA-
Sightseeing-Luftballonprojekts in diesem Jahr
und der Freisetzung in den erdgebundenen
verstandenen Sir und so Autos auf der Erde
Bedingungen wie sogar auf der Unterseite
ist dies eine vier Sie öffnete kein Geschenk
der Taliban Geben Sie Diamant dieser SAR
Verlängerung einer Telefonrechnung  Turbinen
effizient Malenchenko und Aki Zack fanden
einen Asteroidenverschluss Yoga Angie's in einer
Seekrankheit assoziiert einen Grund ja ich denke,
dass unser Verlust des Medikaments eine riesige Kluft
zwischen der größeren Stadt und einer kleineren
Stadt noch kühleren Gegend ist und mit der Zeit
werden wird  schnell
tiefer und tiefer leider und große
Städte Viele Dinge, die
sich für Frauen geändert haben, sie können zur Schule gehen,
sie können Unternehmerinnen werden,
sie können zu den Medien gehen, als politische
Entscheidungsträgerin oder in der Regierung arbeiten, aber
wenn du zum Herrscher gehst  Bereich immer noch die
Taliban Taliban-Kultur wird mit
den Menschen zusammengerufen und die Menschen bevorzugen, dass
das Mädchen in jungen Jahren verheiratet wird. Die
Menschen sehen die Frau immer noch als zweite
Bürgerin an und sie hat ihre  brauchte Zeit, aber
auch als Werkzeuge, die wir brauchten, um
nicht nur Technologie in eine qualitativ hochwertige
Bildung in der Großstadt zu bringen. Ich glaube, dass die
Regierung solche Dinge auch auf Herrscherflächen investieren sollte,
und sie sollten nicht
vergessen, dass die Hälfte der Bevölkerung immer
noch dort lebt  und wenn wir
es heute nicht investieren, haben wir vielleicht eine Gefahr
in der Zukunft und Dunkelheit in der Zukunft,
und ich verstehe, dass wir mit den
afghanischen Präsidenten sprechen, ich meine mit
nicht nur mit einigen anderen Leuten,
wenn Afghanistan sich nicht nur auf Afghanistan
konzentriert  Durch den Krieg und den Kampf
gegen die Taliban werden sie die
Zukunft dieser Generation verlieren, weil wir
die Hälfte der Bevölkerung haben,
die ihre afghanischen Regierungen nicht nur brauchten,
sondern auch politische Entscheidungsträger und und und die
Investition in die gute Qualität der
Bildung, die wir noch haben  40 Prozent
der Bevölkerung, die junge Generation,
haben keinen Job. Was wir also tun können, ist
natürlich, dass die Investitionen in das Militär heute
erforderlich sind, aber wir mussten auch
t  Denken Sie daran, dass wir eine ANA-
Strategie entwickeln mussten, um an der zukünftigen
Generation und ihren Arbeitsfähigkeiten zu arbeiten, damit
sie die Beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten schaffen können
und geschaffen haben, dass eine Wirtschaft wächst, und
es ist heute nur eine Gebühr passiert, wenn man an
diese Generation denkt, und das ist sogar eine gute
Erwähnung  und bleibe Tsuki sogar
investieren, sogar diesen Besuch so viel Pinvidic
gewesen, so Fran Fran Fran ungeborene Seele Ich
fand endlich einen Hobbit Paul Anka GI
Nephilim Perlhuhnvirus, der
Verleihung MD von Pocono hackte Nukleotidbefehle
im Telefon von Souffl, einem sicheren
Partner in New Jersey  dieser
Frauen sind vertrauensvoller, es gibt
verlässliche Partner und außerdem sind
sie das Herz der Bevölkerung
einer Gemeinschaft, und wenn wir heute nicht in sie
investieren, können wir keinen Erfolg haben
und wir können die Wirtschaft im Land nicht so wachsen lassen
Wir mussten in
die Hälfte der Bevölkerung investieren, um eine gute
Ausbildung zu erhalten und finanzielle Unabhängigkeit zu erlangen, und
wenn eine Frau die guten Fähigkeiten erwirbt, kann
sie diese zur Gesellschaft beitragen  ety und am
wichtigsten, sie tragen zu Ihren
Familien und dann zur Gesellschaft in der
Gemeinde bei, denn für mich gibt
es viele Dinge für die Männer, viele
Möglichkeiten für sie und es gibt sie und ich bin
sicher, dass die Regierung und die
Gemeinde sie unterstützen  Aber es ist sehr
wichtig für mich, was ich für meine Generation tun kann,
für Frauen wie mich und
mich und meine Mutter und meine Cousinen,
also was wir für sie tun können, ist
glückliche Technologien und Bildung hat
mir geholfen, mein Leben zu
verändern  für mich, der
Gemeinschaft etwas zurückzugeben, und ich zog es vor,
mit einer Frau zu arbeiten, und ich hatte sie, um die Ziele zu erreichen,
die sie wollen, und die Träume, die
sie im Kopf haben, und was ich tue,
ist, ihnen nur die Werkzeuge zu geben, was es an ihnen liegt
Sie wollen mit Ihrem Leben tun, das
sie in der Flaute gab, also exci Chiffon-
Gebäude Millage Chiton über einem CEO
Thunfisch-Stylist ehrgeizige Natur und sehen Sie
unseren natürlichen Maori-Männer-Film-Anhang-Ereignis
und fügen Sie sogar Vermittler-Lachs ein, sind
bitin wie jede Plattform von th  Ihr Thron
unserer Männer, unsere Ohrstöpsel, starten Kanonenreihen,
Vlogs, als Videoblöcke, Ohrring,
Blechinterviews, gehen beladen auf der
surinamischen Vorstellung, die Geschirre in der
Philosophie, die auf der Tradition auftauchen, bekamen einen,
also nicht einmal ein Häkchen, als gelieferte
Segundos, fertig mit Argumenten und
Vitae  Gemeinsame Phänomene Jackies neue
Medienverhandlung mit Info-Building-
Meeting-Zeit und visuell auf den
via APIs ein Plastik Alison nur anständig,
also hing Lachs in Tracys Aufnahme sehr.
Ich danke Ganesh sehr, dass sie auf
Afghanistans Land in unsicherem
Kapitän baut und ehrlich gesagt,
gut, die Omni investieren jetzt  Hammerstein
ist auf Afghanistan gebaut und entflohen
ist als gebildeter oder hörender Schacht beteiligt
zv haben die felsham baucops nackt
auf afghanistan ich denke
das gibt es ehrlich gesagt
ar  Das Bild, das Sie gerade hervorheben,
dass es wahrscheinlich 10 oder 20 Prozent gibt, dass es
ein Leben in Afghanistan gibt, dass 44
Millionen Menschen dort leben
und viele von ihnen glücklich leben, viele
von ihnen, wir haben unsere eigene Ehe, wir haben
unsere eigenen Partys, die wir haben  unsere eigenen Schulen,
wir haben unsere eigenen Hoffnungen und Träume für
die Zukunft,
und leider berichten die Medien nicht
darüber, dass der Verlust erfolgreicher
Geschichten dort passiert, dass viele
erfolgreiche Unternehmerinnen damit beschäftigt sind, aber
es gibt auch viele gute
Dinge, die in Afghanistan passieren und was  Wir
mussten ihnen eine Hoffnung geben, wir können die
Veer-Hoffnungen nicht zurückbekommen, und leider wird auch
unseren Medien nur Dunkelheit gezeigt, und
Dunkelheit wird unserem Land nicht helfen
Sagen Sie das einfach und
leider sehe ich viele
Südafrikaner, die die klügsten Kinder
verlassen haben, die Afghanistan verlassen haben, und
es hilft meinem Kimchi nicht, wieder aufzubauen, und was
wir ne  Heute geht es darum, zu investieren und
Halt zu geben und zusammenzuarbeiten,
um unsere Gemeinschaft aufzubauen, um eine bessere
Zukunft für uns selbst zu haben, und es gibt
viele kluge Kinder in Afghanistan, viele
Talente und mit vielen Träumen und
Hoffnungen für morgen und  Was
ich als Bürger tun kann, ist,
so vielen Menschen wie möglich ein Werkzeug zur Macht zu geben,
und ich möchte auch
sagen, dass
wir im Juni hoffentlich eine Konferenz abhalten werden
Die größte Konferenz zur Technologieinnovation wird
für
weibliche junge Jugendliche stattfinden, und in der Dad's
Conference mit der Ausstellung der
Präsentation vieler junger Talente
, die ihre eigenen Startups in
verschiedenen Branchen gegründet haben, gibt es Frauen und
die junge Generation, die daran
arbeiten, ein Rennen aufzubauen  Auto Es gibt eine junge
Generation, die daran arbeitet, den
Roboter für die Industrie zu bauen, also
mussten wir uns darauf konzentrieren, uns
auf sie zu konzentrieren und in sie zu investieren und ihnen zu helfen
, ihre Zukunft aufzubauen  Wir können nicht einfach
den Krieg und das unsichere 'ti als
Grund dafür bringen, dass wir nicht an
die nächste Generation denken oder keine
Investitionen in die Talente in
Afghanistan investieren müssen. Wir brauchen nicht so viele
Spenden, aber wir brauchten Investitionen und Spenden
Richten Sie an die Menschen, dass sie
Ihre eigene Zukunft aufbauen können, sie
werden so gute Bürger, wie sie
Wissen haben, das wir eigentlich brauchten,
und dann brauchten wir Investitionen,
um die Startups und den Aufbau
in unserer Gemeinde aufzubauen, und das ist es, was wir
heute brauchten Sierra  Nevada koffeinfreier
Stefan verkaufte auch ein paar
hängende Treffen in ethnischen
Beziehungen. Wir waren Keynote-Sprecher
anon
World Web Form des Digital Easy
Wer arbeitet natürlich Visi Dies ist der Bereich
Mason in der zweiten wissen in Vevey
Kommunikation ständiges Sperrfeuer in Ovid
bald riesig  Das Vandy-Team und der Besuch können
seinen Ökonomen nicht helfen, den Genotyp zu
vermitteln. Varlamov, nicht Mia, innoviert allein.
Zuallererst bin ich wirklich dankbar für das
World Web für Sie f  oder bringen Sie mich hierher,
fügen Sie Schräglage ein und geben Sie mir die Möglichkeit,
über die öffentliche Vorstellungskraft und
die Geschichte von mir und der Arbeit, die sie tun
, zu sprechen, aber entschuldigen Sie bitte Ihre Frage,
was es war, was das Fernsehen zumindest durch die
Eindämmung der ng denken Behinderung in
Verlegenheit gebracht hatte  an der Gitarre ist er zu
Hause Ozzie widerstehen Ich denke, das
Wichtigste ist, Zugang
zu den Menüs der Frau zu gewähren, die wir brauchen, um Zugang zu den Menüs
der Frau zu gewähren, die keine Welt haben, hinter der sie stehen,
wenn die Welt sich vorwärts bewegt, ohne dass
ihnen Zugang und Konnektivität das
Erste sind  Dinge, die wir umsetzen müssen
, und zweitens haben sie das
Wissen geschaffen und ihnen Fähigkeiten gegeben,
wie sie diese Technologie verwenden können
, um ein besseres Leben für sich selbst zu schaffen
und Ihr Leben und auch das Ihrer
Gemeinschaften zu verbessern, was ich heute tue  Denken ist,
dass
die
meisten Länder wie unser
Land Zugang zu den technischen Geräten
und dem Wissen haben müssen, um im 21. Jahrhundert vollständig und erfolgreich zu sein  Denken Sie daran, dass die Veränderung unserer
Umwelt und die Veränderung
der Welt so
leider nicht alles in Afghanistan ist, aber es
gibt
in vielen Ländern einen ungleichen Zugang zu Bildung, wenn
Sie sich das reichste Land und das
ärmste Land dort ansehen  Lücke
zwischen ihnen Wir haben immer noch keinen Zugang
zu den Informationen Wir haben keinen Zugang
zum Internet und es gibt dort reichste
Länder, die an die nächsten
zehn Jahre denken, dass sich alles um einen Ich
werde das kontrollieren oder Roboter werden das kontrollieren
, das ist eine riesige Lücke, die wir haben  Ich rede davon, dass
wir diesen Ländern auch
den gleichen Zugang geben mussten, um den Landsleuten den gleichen Zugang zu gewähren,
aber su vista Digitalism East
Ehrgeiz in diesem Samba Cardinals
Granlund und erschoss einen Neun-Tropfen-Mann
Absalom der Angst einen Schwung und escutia
sogar die Angst um ihren Abschluss
bis gegen die Sonne die Arbeit unserer
Haut kann über ihn sagen der Youngster
Anubhava Home Finley tut E  lizabeth
readin dann congee kochte aus Malaysia
freiheit that offensiv fügte hinzu koch
malaysia mukesh vieh Duberstein Ich
denke, dass es nicht so übertrieben ist,
aber ich denke auch, dass wir
dies als Chance sehen müssen, und ich bin sicher, dass
es nicht alles nehmen wird  der Job, aber
es hat mehr Jobs geschaffen, viele Jobs,
die in der KI geschaffen wurden, und das macht ihr
Leben für die Menschen einfacher, aber
es gibt auch wieder eine Verantwortung
, die damit einhergeht, wie wir das auch nutzen
, wenn wir diese Art von
Jobs annehmen  es kann schaffen, dass ähnliche
Arbeitsplätze in Hightech oder Technologie für
die Menschen geschaffen werden, und ich bin mir sicher, dass der
Verlust der Führungskräfte und der Technologietechnologie
darüber spricht, und sie
arbeiten daran, und sie, sie, sie haben
für die Besorgnis geantwortet  der Menschen
, aber ich habe die Befürchtung,
dass das Land wie wir immer noch
Menschen sind, die auf sehr traditionelle Weise leben,
und sie verwenden nicht viele von ihnen, nicht einmal eine
von zehn Frauen in Afrika, zum Beispiel sie
Sie haben noch nie einen Computer gesehen, was wir sind,
so hinter der Welt, die sich
ohne uns vorwärts bewegt, und das ist eine
Herausforderung  Oglala Angst 10% eine
Lobby Rufus in Frankreich auf ein Drehbuch in
Sperrfeuer Angriff Porsche eine
Musketeninitiative auf Sean eine statische Funktion, während
wir Tech
OT schlagen Ei auf Chakra Premier
Vielfalt im Tech-Porsche eine abscheuliche
Essenz t Teams einen Schlagstock besa eine
Vielfalt annehmen  Überfall auf bloße Produktivität
männliche Innovation Abbas ist auch 32 Land
bei einem digitalen Auftrag, den
wir in Bambietta als konservativ empfanden,
aber können sie das
Produkt zugeben, der US-Männer-Assistent, wir schneiden
faule Sünden, ja, das stimmt, und ich
denke, dass wir an diesen
sieben arbeiten mussten  In Restaurantländern landen Analysatoren,
dass die Frauen in jungen Jahren
Zugang haben, um zu verstehen, dass die
Innovation und warum Technologie gut
für sie ist  und wir mussten den
Kindern in jungen Jahren mehr beibringen, insbesondere
Programmieren und Engineering für Frauen, und meine
Umgebung so aufregend machen, dass sie aufregender
sind, mehr weibliche
Vorbilder zu haben, die die Frauen sehen,
dass es okay ist, dass es viele Frauen gibt
und sind  in der Technik oder in Ingenieuren, also
würden sie es vorziehen, dorthin zu gehen,
und ich denke, dass es
Frauen aufgrund der Umwelt vielleicht nicht
wohl dabei ist, in sehr Vans zu fahren, wenn sie
zum Beispiel ein oder zwei von zehn zehn Personen
der Motor sind, denke ich  In einem großen
Unternehmen sind mehr Männer als
Frauen, so dass sie sich nicht wohl
fühlen, dorthin zu gehen, aber wenn wir
in eine Tech-Unternehmerin investieren, wenn wir
mehr Frauen als Vorbilder bringen und wir
die Kinder in jungen Jahren unterrichten, aber
Kodierung und Engineering speziell
für Frauen, vielleicht können wir diese Lücke schließen,
aber ja, ich sehe, dass dies auch im Westen ein Problem ist,
aber was
wir in unserem Land tun, ist, dass
wir in jungen Jahren versuchen, zu unterrichten, und ich
t  Denken Sie, dass Technologie auch die großen
Werkzeuge für die Frau in den konservativen
Ländern ist, weil sie wegen der kulturellen Teenager zu Hause bleiben können,
aber
trotzdem sehr arbeiten können, aber auch, wie sie
freundlich sind, Computer können oft eine
übertriebene und gemessene Anmeldung auslösen Leah von
Peters  Hier hinter Haken zu diesem
winzigen Tech-Unternehmer im Silicon
Valley, der uns geholfen hat, unsere Brötchen FM, die
Sixtinischen Fitness-Tracker Otesaga und
Pfunde Mitch Diamond ist zurück mit dem
Dämon, der auf Herzl zu Saginaw Hannah
Lukesh Los Molinos gekommen ist, und hat die
Apple-Gesundheitsexpertin bewertet, die ja Zeit hervorgebracht hat
Alkanes Philadelphia Mason über Oscar
Ethnizität Food Park Ich sage unseren Divas
erzählte unsere Garnitur in einem studierten Film als
Mann Definition von Apps in betrügerischer Bräune
es ist eine Art Hochskalierung der Strenge von
Nyssa aus Florida und leicht nach dem
Bidadi-Patent Aladeen-Sonnenwende im
Silicon Valley zeigt, dass jeglicher Sexismus entkommen ist
auf der sphärischen tief
in dieser emotion verbirgt sich dieses vehikel nach italienischem
liebblick einer fickerei  verstecken özkan
sexistische Maschinengewehre landen und flossen
Indiens Allison Pearson V Leiden eine
kindische Vergangenheit war real oder Sexismus spuckt
Iseman Ich denke, dass ich über
den Fall des Silicon Valley viel gehört habe und
wahrscheinlich gibt es einige Dinge, die sie
und das Gute haben  ist bei mir in
Bewegung, es fing an, darüber zu sprechen,
und Frauen, über die ich anfange
, darüber zu sprechen  Das
ist ein Problem, das wir
in allen von Männern dominierten Branchen haben,
das den Frauen ein unangenehmes Gefühl gibt,
also haben wir weniger Frauen in diesem Bereich,
aber wenn wir darüber reden können und
wir diese Probleme in die
Politik einbringen können  Macher, Regierungen und die Menschen
und die Gemeinschaften und Kooperativen, es
wird eine Menge Veränderungen bringen. Ich weiß nicht
, ob ich Ihre Fragen beantwortet habe,
oder es war ein anderer Mann in der gezeigten
Stadt, die nicht warten kann  r turbine see hat eine
neuere Art von Jets genug, um
Bescheid zu geben, um sofort
zu sehen  Wählen Sie:
Frau Azam Khan und Leine am Start, also mm
Hamdi sozial und median, dann in
Ära Dampf
geworfen  Als Freunde
sprechen wir viel über diese Probleme,
und viele meiner Freunde,
die in USD leben, sprechen darüber, dass
dies die Art von Problemen sind, mit denen sie
jeden Tag konfrontiert sind, oder dass sie Teil Ihres täglichen
Lebens sind, wenn die Anforderungen aggressiv sind oder
Verhaltensweisen werden in manchen Fällen nicht angepasst,
und ich denke, dass wir wieder mit
Social Media oder mit der Meet-You-Bewegung
diese Ergänzungen bringen mussten, die wir brauchten
, um Veränderungen in der sich verändernden Umgebung
für die Frau herbeizuführen  n und Frau sollten sich frei
und sicher fühlen, wenn sie arbeiten wollten oder
sogar zum Investor gehen wollten, um
die Investition zu erhalten, und
leider gibt es einige Fälle
, in denen die Regierung nicht investiert,
wenn sie nicht auf die
angeforderten Kinder reagieren und  Was wir brauchten
, war, mehr Frauen zu haben, um in die Frau zu investieren,
und auch, um diese
Dinge mehr zu machen, um ein Tizian des
politischen Entscheidungsträgers zu sein. Ich weiß nicht, dass jede Genossenschaft
sich ändern müsste, und ich denke, dass
wir mehr Frauen brauchen
Führungspositionen, um dies zu ändern, und mehr Frauen
, die in die Frau investieren, und Frauen
sollten Frauen dabei unterstützen, dass wir einige Veränderungen herbeiführen können,
und den Männern helfen
, ihr Verhalten zu verstehen, dann die
Vielfalt der Exemplare im emotionalen
Famteam unter all dem Flex von nicht
Tonnen von Körper  Zählungen von Kakatiya und der
Garagenverwerfung Ich war Kiptyn und
respektierte den Diversity-Namen Mr.  bash
Billy Frog eine große gesprochene englische Erwähnung
in Underland auf in London cultura 900
Shona Spezialist die App m-pesa widersteht
jeder Apathie unter nur ungezählten,
begeisterten Smartphone-Bataillonskandidaten
in Afrika zu besuchen gsfe bemerkte auf uns die
Unsicherheit Tandem schüchtern ist zu markieren und
uns das  entwicklung von apps Wenn der
Leckagekanal des Pedersen-Kanals ein Maßblatt ist
, das Condon über
Christensen erwähnt hat, habe ich angestellt, eine Zeitschrift gesehen, die die
Emission von Villa Canada
soo-hyun überwacht, weil zystische Ferne
schnappt, ich vermisse Vida, Ermittler, DeShawns
SFL, Harbinson, sagen Horizonte auf dieser
Insel  bin ich geistesabwesend gekommen komm auf
video nach hause trostlos
absanon entfesselt von owenton ihr haus
wien grassroot pavillons von 270 abwesend
11 ich denke dass investoren wenn sie
in die verschiedenen länder gehen um zu investieren und
sie wollen dass ihre apps ihre leute benutzen
das wenn sie es tun  Wenn dies nicht auf der Grundlage der
Bedürfnisse der Qualitätskultur und der
Bedürfnisse der Menschen geschieht, können sie nicht
länger erfolgreich sein  Zeit, die sie
vielleicht kurzfristig haben, eine kurze Zeit, aber
sie brauchten das, um
am Lou-Zusammenbruch zu arbeiten
Leider geht es nicht nur um
App und wir sehen es im Himmel mit dem
Geld, das sie von internationalen
Gemeinschaften bekommen, sie treffen Ihre Entscheidung, sie
denken vielleicht, dass dies das ist, was
die Menschen brauchen, und sie bringen
es zur Sprache, und manchmal funktioniert es nicht,
weil sie es tun  verstehen die
kulturellen Barrieren nicht, sie verstehen nicht,
was genau eine Frau braucht oder was
genau ein Mann braucht, und dass die Gesellschaft
so etwas investiert oder ein Programm
oder ein Projekt bringt, Sir, und Vielfalt ist sehr
wichtig, denn wenn wir das bringen
Frau ist in der Tabelle und sie verstehen,
wie zum Beispiel ich verstehe, welche
Farbe ich wollte, was ich heute brauchte, und ich habe
gespendet, dass es für
Innovationen geschaffen wurde, wenn Sie t bringen  die frau und
in der tabelle weil gefährlich und was
sie braucht und was wirklich
notwendig ist für die gesellschaft als
perspektive einer frau und das
bringt mehr innovative ideen
innovative projekte geschaffen
innovativere ideen viele warten auf
produkte und auf uns zum beispiel was  Wir
machen es in unserem Programm, wenn wir mehr
Form und mehr Frauen bringen, sehen wir, dass
Frauen einheimischer sind und an
den Sachen arbeiten, die wir haben und
wir oder unsere Männer haben nicht darüber nachgedacht
, weil sie an das Allgemeine denken
Sachen und dann den Tag okay und lass uns das machen
, aber die Frau bringt es, obwohl
das kein Problem ist, ist das ein Problem darin
, und dann können sie
gute und gleichgestellte Produkte für unsere
Gemeinschaft oder Gesellschaft finden und sind ähnlich
Überall brauchten wir
eine vielfältige Gruppe, nicht nur Frauen, sondern
auch Minderheiten und Menschen mit Behinderungen, sie
müssen alle zusammenkommen und ein
Umfeld schaffen, in dem sie eine
Entscheidung treffen und einbringen können  Innovativere
Produkte, denn was wir
heute
brauchen, ist die ultimative Erleichterung, da
Cloacal Ihr eigener globaler, einfacher Mensch vor Ort ist.
Denken Sie nach und hören Sie sich etwas an, das
ich gespielt habe
auf
Casilla Danke, dass du mich hier hast
[Musik]
du